one of the most difficult tasks is to
improve something that's already very
good says our reviewer Lionel Dyson over
there'll be a lot of complaints if it
doesn't work but if it does work it'll
make everyone really happy the
mercedes-benz beat class has sold well
since the last version came out in 2005
the first generation sold 700,000 cars
and the second added another three
hundred eighty thousand that means over
a million satisfied customers around the
world let's see what the latest version
can do after Mercedes made the a-class
Fortier in west of an MPV the beat class
now has to broaden its appeal it's
therefore been refreshed and looks
somewhat more athletic most of the
design changes are at the front end
front end as a new bumper explains
Mercedes deer striker
the headlights have been subtly changed
and the nose is a slightly different
look there are simple alterations but
together they give a far different
overall impression the new headlights
now have integrated daytime running
lights both in the standard lamps and
also in the optional full LED headlights
mundo in an optional heading for
addition of the B class has an appealing
new exterior but the really interesting
changes are inside our test car had 155
kilowatts of power the engines in the
new B class have it optimized for low
fuel consumption the top engine consumes
a maximum of six point six liters of
premium fuel per 100 kilometers with
4matic all-wheel drive but that option
isn't just reserved at the top of the
line model the compact cars development
chief says there are now four engines
with all-wheel-drive the two most
powerful gasoline units and two diesels
he says this is the broadest all-wheel
range in its segment
environmentally friendly models round
out the b-class range the electrically
powered model can be charged within
three and a half hours from a standard
power outlet until now the US has been
the main market for the electric B Class
now Mercedes hopes to find new buyers in
Germany electric vehicle development
chief Jurgen Schenk says the firm is
pursuing a three-pronged strategy one
involves improve conventional internal
combustion engines both diesel and
gasoline then there are plug-in hybrids
for the middle segment and electric
vehicles for completely emission free
driving Mercedes already offers this
with the b-class electric drive which it
hopes to build upon in the future
visually the electric version stands out
with optimal blue trim and decals on the
side in the US the electric beat class
has already found some celebrity buyers
Ryan Tedder lead singer of One Republic
is an electric convert
electric cars to me it is the future I
think that eventually everything is
going to be electric it's June I just
think it's inevitable you know all you
have to do is spend drive through a
tunnel with the windows down and breathe
that stuff in and you realize that we
need to shift everything to electric
it's just because it's just you can
finally experience how bad all the
exhaust is and what it's actually doing
the environment when driving the
electric version the loudest thing you
hear is tire noise during development
Mercedes set itself the goal a meeting
customer demand for an everyday car with
a long range the b-class electric drive
runs 200 kilometers in the European
driving cycle but the car also boasts a
range-extended button on individual days
you can recharge the battery to more
than normal then the b-class has a range
of 230 kilometers with the on-board 11
kilowatt charger a full charge typically
takes around three and a half hours a
100 kilometer charge takes approximately
one hour we'll just one day inside there
is the typical mercedes design and
top-class workmanship a flatters
steering wheel and round instruments
provide a sporty touch flexibility is a
major selling point of the b-class the
rear seats can be moved and of course
folded down the b-class can stow between
501 and 1456 liters of cargo
what elephant spinal says modern
vehicles primarily different three ways
in terms of design engines and assist
systems the newbie class has collision
prevention assist plus as standard that
means if the driver is distracted or
daydreaming and an obstacle appears a
car breaks to a stop by itself thereby
preventing a collision let's take a look
at how it works
Helen Tom Bissell instant confident
atado
then alpha-alpha own dust problem is das
the white beat class is on a collision
course the speed is 45 km/h typical for
city traffic
Reinhold steps on the gas that beat
class responds it worked wonderfully for
Mercedes it's mission accomplished the
new beat class has sharper lines the
engines are more efficient and the beat
class is safer to the previous collision
avoidance system led to a 14% reduction
in severe rear-end collisions and the
new system is twice as safe the 130
kilowatt electric v class has a 200
kilometer range the B classes broad
product range will likely mean sound
sales figures there's something for
nearly everyone both are tested top
gasoline model and the emission free
electric variant cost just under 40,000
euros in Germany